- Hey, my name is Leslie Odom Jr.
- Eli Goree.
- Kingsley Ben-Adir
- This is Aldis Hodge
and this is how it became Jim Brown.
- I became Malcolm X.
- Became Cassius clay.
- And this is how I became Sam Cooke.
(upbeat music)
I remember when I was a little
boy, my dad pointed out to me
one time the Swan, little
family of swans was grazing
or was slowly like going
like that across on water,
top of the water.
And he said, do you see those?
Yeah, sure.
He said, so you see
how graceful they look.
And he said, underneath the water,
you know, talking about
the amount of effort
underneath grace, the
amount of effort underneath
what Sam had crafted,
which was this unflappable
smooth, professional,
sexy, appealing thing.
there was great effort
holding that all together
and racking up those accomplishments.
That is the strength of a vision.
So I say that to say the thing
that I learned most about him
in my discovery, it's
right there in chem script.
And, as I went to do the
research, I discovered,
Oh that's why you put it in there.
Sam wasn't nothing to play with.
Sam was a firebrand,
like nobody was pushing
Sam around anywhere ever.
So yeah, I wanted that
side of him showing,
not just that calm exterior
that we know him for.
- Well, this is off to a hopping start.
- Whenever it's stepping into the shoes
of someone who was real,
you wanna do your best
to honor this person
and respect their legacy
and really celebrate what they've done.
And for me, at first I didn't know
if I was up to the charge.
I didn't know if I could be here.
And I was looking out study.
I was like, can I beat this guy?
I don't know, So, you know, I didn't know,
but after the audition came
around, the opportunity
to audition came around a
couple of times I was like,
you know what, let me step
into this, give it a shot
because there's a reason
it's coming back around.
So, I auditioned and during that process,
I really just looked at at
who he was studied as much
information as I could when it
came to videos and interviews
and studying his cadence and
how he spoke and how he moved
and even how he handled altercation.
But mostly it was about
understanding his mentality
to really get into the mindset
and the essence of Mr. Brown.
- Nice ain't it Malcolm?
- Its most definitely soothing Cass.
- I Started kind of
working on the character
a while before this film even
but I had another opportunity
to do an audition for another
film that I didn't get.
So I just, I was working
on the character for awhile
but I was looking for a dialect
coach and, and a producer
from a film I had worked
on before called race.
I was asking her if she knew
any good dialect coaches.
And she introduced me to someone
who introduced me to Trey
and we worked together from
the first time I'd heard
about the audition till I
got to meet Regina and then
all the way through the
shooting process so,
it was pretty long.
It was like, you know, nine
months that we were just
like working three times a
week for an hour and a half.
And then when we were on set,
probably even more than that
like every day for about
an hour and we really
nailed down the Southern
accent and he kind of helped me
to understand the culture of
the South and how that affects
the voice, and how that
affects the perspective
of a young black man.
I think that helped me really
get into the scanner and body
where, where Cassius was
coming from, from the roots.
And then when we put
everything else on top of that
foundation, it just felt very
grounded and very natural.
So I think that's probably
when, when I really felt
like I had a handle on
just the Southern accent.
There was a phrase that
I, it was like a phrase
that he says all the time to champ.
- We're all coming back here
for the champs of victory party
Don't be late.
- It never felt right
coming out of my mouth.
Like I'm the champ, you
know, I'm the world's champ.
And it was just like, for
some reason it was just,
it was just awkward for a long time.
And there would be times
when I would say it
and just be like, did
that sound right to you?
Did that sound real or authentic?
And then after a while like
it became more comfortable
but yeah, for some reason
champ just like many times
it just didn't quite feel right.
- I figured I better start
getting my life story documented
in my own words while I can.
- I think a really important
moment was in the reading of it
before I'd even attempted to
ingest any of the language
or attempt any of the dialect.
That was, it was reading
Kemps words and really trying
to understand from an acting point of view
like what the function of
Malcolm was within this piece.
And then I read it again and I was like,
the emotional undercurrent,
his heartbeat is,
it was a vulnerability
about him in the words
that felt very unique and I was like
oh it's just an opportunity,
its a kind of play or explore
you know Malcolm in a
really different way.
And then I started sort of
investigating what the stakes
actually were for Malcolm at
this particular moment in time.
And he was on a band and
there was a real sense
that he was being pushed
out of the nation of Islam
and that his days were numbered.
I think he was beginning
to understand that.
And there was a real sense that his life
was about to be in real danger.
I'm not sure if that the death threats
were kind of just starting to happen.
The FBI were really up his ass in big way.
They were onto him.
And I think that was
understanding all of that
before anything was the
most important thing.
And Regina and I, you know,
when we jumped on the phone
after she saw my sort of interpretation
in my audition tapes,
that's what we spoke about.
We spoke about Malcolm and
the father, and the husband
and the vulnerability of his situation
at this time was everything.
And then just, you know,
then it was just a pure joy
because I was kind of set free by lots
of the Gregory's words on Malcolm.
X said that Malcolm had
confided in him around this time
and said that he felt
weak and he felt hollow.
And no one knew the torments
that he went through
as his relationship with
the nation was ending.
And Dick said that he, you know
if Malcolm could hear us
now, it'd be embarrassed.
He was really a sweet and bashful man.
And then the laceration
demagogue that we all know
that kind of stereotypical
image was really a character
that Malcolm slipped in and out of
but wasn't the sum total of who he was.
And when we do see Malcolm on
YouTube and those, you know
those classic images of
him, so often it's Malcolm
in response to the most
hideous instances of racism,
just happened that day or the day before.
And we kind of, you know
that image is really
what so many people know of
him but I was really excited
about the opportunity to
explore the other side.
- We want a world where we
are safe to be ourselves.
- There was one interview,
like I watched so many documentaries,
you know Antoine Fuqua
did a great one called
"What's My Name."
And there's the Spike Lee
classic of "When We Were Kings."
And I watched lots of
interviews and read books,
blood brothers was the book
that I went to that gave
me a lot of information.
But probably every day
for at least three months,
there was an interview
that I found on YouTube
of him when he's about 20
years old before he had
his first professional, his
first championship fight
on local Louisville radio.
Just an interview with a fighter,
and people were just calling
in asking him questions
for about an hour and a half.
And it was really, really
cool because you learn so much
about how he had to balance
this persona with the reality
of being a black man in the South.
And he was just really, he was so smart.
There was the moment I was
probably listening to it
for about two weeks every morning
before I realized that
there's a moment where
there's a KKK member who
calls in and you don't,
I didn't realize it at first,
but when you listen back
and listen back then you realize that
he's threatening him in code.
And Cassius is trying to
maintain his disposition.
This really happened,
You can go look it up.
His disposition as this
braggadocious champ,
but at the same time realizing
his life is on the line
once he steps outside
of this radio station
and the way he knew was the conversation
and manages answers to these questions,
was just, he's a genius, you
know, at such a young age.
So wise beyond his years.
So that was an interview
that I listened to every day
for months and months and
months, not just for the dialect
but just also to see
how his mind operated,
and how he processed things,
and how we overcame challenges
and how he interacted with fans.
There was just so many
gems in that interview.
- The goal is for us to really be free.
- I wanted to showcase the
strength and confidence
of knowing himself and knowing his value.
When I did research, I realized
how forthcoming he was,
rather forthright he
was about understanding
who he was in this time in a
space where a lot of people
openly spoke against him because
of the color of his skin.
They celebrated him on the field,
but spoke against him behind closed doors
but he didn't let that deteriorate.
He only left ladder to push
him before and understand
and even share the value of
taking control of his narrative.
His understanding of economic
power in the community.
He allowed it to motivate
him for progress.
So I really wanted to
display that side of this man
who really was quite
intellectual on the subject
of what it means when it
comes to getting control
of your potential and
completely taking charge
and pushing forward.
- But we are fighting for our lives!
- You know I know what's
going on out there, right?
- Well, Leslie and I, before
we started shooting that stuff
we kind of agreed between us quietly
that we were both open to
kind of throw in each other
and trying things out
and playing games and,
you know, just staying
open to the possibility
of surprising each other.
And it was kind of tough at times.
And when we went in and
especially, I went really hard
and heavy on Leslie in that first week
in that we shot that
scene in the room fast
and I sort of took no prisoners in
and laid into him relentlessly for a week.
And there was something
really interesting about that.
It was kind of difficult and uncomfortable
cause we didn't know each other.
And it was really the first
few days of filming, but yeah,
Leslie and I, it was,
yeah, it was a joy to get
to really try and bring those
scenes to life with him.
- Everything's not so black and white,
like you make it out to be.
- I mean, the argument
was all laid out for us
in Kemp's beautiful script.
I recognize that Kemp wanted
to do something daring.
He wanted to have a private
conversation publicly.
These are conversations that
I witnessed first as a boy,
I witnessed my parents
and adults around me
having conversations like this.
And as an adult, I started
to have them myself.
And there was something a little dangerous
about this script.
I couldn't quite put my finger on it,
cause usually the way that we
push boundaries in film are,
I mean, the usual ways I think
are probably like violence
or sex, you know, it's very rare.
It is a boundary pushed in
film through an argument,
through talking dialogue.
So, I thought that was really exciting.
And yeah, it's just, I guess the age old
back and forth of can you, is
the only way to change things.
There are people that believe you have
you can only change
things from the inside.
And, there's the other adage
that says, you have to divest.
You can't build anything
worthwhile in your master's house.
You know that you have to go
and build your own thing outside of that.
So, it's a real push and
pull the only not fight
that I had with, with
brother Kemp but I remember
because Kingsley as
Malcolm having coming at me
in that hotel room for days
before I got to respond
might just land into me.
And there's really nowhere for that to go,
for that tension to go
until you get to respond
the tension just lives in your body.
So there was this one
weekend before I shot
my side of the argument
and I was like, Kemp,
I need more, but you got it.
Like, cause because Malcolm
has compelling arguments,
he's brilliant.
And Kingsley's is brilliant at playing.
- Your record is gonna
stand the test of time.
- For me to widen out my
face, I wore these plumpers,
which I fit between my jaws on both sides
what made it look a little
interesting to try to eat.
But I had those in my
mouth all day to speak
and try to give me a little roundup.
So you kind of have to work
around how you speak with that
because it's like basically
having a weird set of braces.
And yeah, they sometimes they
painted on some of the scars
but I actually had some bumpy knuckles.
So, some of that was real.
(laughing) That was real.
And then I just had to
size up a little bit.
I had to get in the gym
a little bit more for,
cause you know, the small
brother, you know he was swollen.
So, I had to get up and able to push ups.
You know, I'm confident
in my skill set but I,
a part of that confidence
comes a little bit
of assurance comes afterwards.
While I'm working, I'm
always maintaining the fact
that I need to do the work
and I never get comfortable.
So I never had a moment
where I said, you know what?
I'm in it, admit this is it.
I felt like, keep up the
work, never let your God down,
keep going because you can do better.
You can do more, you can
keep pushing further.
And that sort of repetition allows me
to stay in the constant
state of doing work
so I can keep practicing who he is.
- Oh my goodness!
Why am I so pretty?
(everyone groans)
I hired Trey personally, out of my own,
before I had the role, I
hired him as my dialect coach.
I just said, I know what am,
I believe I'm going to play this role.
And he thank God was
like, okay, I'm on board.
Let's do it.
And so I was paying him out of pocket
before I had the role for months.
And then when I got the role,
thank God they brought him on
as the dialect coach for the film.
And then he was a blessing
to all of us from then.
But, you know, in same
thing with the boxing,
like I was training at
East Side Boxing Center
when I was in Vancouver, when
I would shoot on Riverdale.
And then when I'd be in LA,
I would go to different
boxing clubs around LA.
There was a UFC gym out in Torrance
where I worked with guys.
There was Mario,
I can't remember his name
but he's Gabriel Rosado's
personal trainer.
He helped me with my boxing stuff.
Anybody I knew that knew
anything about boxing,
I was, I would try to do
anything I could to just pick up
anything I could, because I
knew I wanted to play this role.
And then from when I got
the role, I got introduced
to Rob Sally who did
the fight choreography
for Creed and for the
Claressa Shields story,
and is a former professional fighter,
a current professional fight
coach and was just phenomenal
and has been a wealth
of knowledge ever since.
- ♪ All together yeah♪ . ♪
- Yeah I know, that was,
it's a weird thing for actors
because we look at a script and you see
something like that a moment.
And then, you know Sam sings A Change
Is Gonna Come on the Tonight Show.
You're like, I wanna do that.
And then right on the
flip side you're like,
but no time soon though,
(laughing) like make
that as late as possible.
And so since this is about
becoming, I'll say on that day
that was my last day of
shooting in new Orleans.
And Sam was never closer to
me than he was on that day.
And that is because, the way I became Sam,
the way that I found my Sam
was through the interrogation
of Kingsley Ben-Adir as Malcolm X
through those relationships
that I developed with Jim
and Cassius and those, you know
my brothers on on that set,
they helped tell me who
I was supposed to be.
I was Sam in relation to
these three other guys.
- Look at this view.
I bet they're doing
them for me (laughing).
(soft upbeat music)